bernard werber écrivain auteur de la
célèbre trilogie les fourmis bonsoir
bernard werber à ses côtés direct par
skype également d'un mattia producteur
de comédies musicales bonsoir à vous
aussi alors la culture qui a été jusqu'à
présent parce que on s'est un petit peu
rattrapé ces derniers jours du côté du
gouvernement ça a été les grands oubliés
ce plan de déconfinement en tout cas
annoncés par edouard philippe lors de
son discours le 28 avril déjà
selon vous pourquoi ce retard à
l'allumage dob à bastia je pense qu'ils
étaient très occupés et pour eux on
n'était peut-être pas prioritaire c'est
la seule raison que je trouve bernard
werber domaine de la culture qui fait
vivre 1,3 million de personnes en france
dans une tribune au journal le monde de
nombreux artistes ont déploré le manque
de soutien du gouvernement vous vous
l'expliquez comment je ne sais pas je ne
suis pas dans les petits secrets du
gouvernement mais je pense qu'en effet
ils vivent une crise qui est vraiment
nouvelle dans lequel il
tout est inventé ce qui se passe c'est
que en effet la culture tout à l'heure
le votre invité précédent disait qu'il y
avait beaucoup de problèmes
psychologiques chez les gens qui
restaient chez eux de dépression il faut
voir que la culture sert aussi à ça
souvent la culture ça arrive en parent
pauvre parce qu'on se dit c'est pas
nécessaire comme la nourriture ou la
santé ou la sécurité
mais c'est nécessaire pour la solidité
psychologique précisément pour ne pas se
disputer à la maison pour avoir une
évasion
actuellement la culture c'est ce qui
permet aux gens de tenir c'est parce
qu'il voit des films parce qu'ils lisent
des livres parce qu'ils écoutent de la
musique que ils sont peut-être un peu
plus détendu sinon les livrer à un
stress qui serait beaucoup plus
difficile à gérer mais encore faut-il
soutenir les artistes c'est quand même
un secteur extrêmement fragile dans
lequel je pense va y avoir beaucoup de
blessés et beaucoup de noms on s'assure
que personne ne voit de quoi vous parlez
évidemment pas de dispute chez personne
à la maison d'env attias
au japon on tenez par exemple il ya des
pièces de théâtre qui ont été joués en
public retransmise en direct sur
internet est ce que ça manque un petit
peu de deux ça finalement en france
d'ailleurs on a très peu entendu le
ministre de la culture à s'exprimer oui
c'est vrai qu'on a été les grands
oubliés donc je comprends qu'il ya des
choses plus urgentes au japon oui je
connais bien puisque une pièce un
spectacle dont je suis le co auteur
d'être diffusé sur les chaînes de télé
pour pallier à la fermeture des théâtres
bon et puis la catastrophe pour nous
c'est tous ces intermittents ces gens
qui font vivre notre métier qui ont un
système un peu compliqué parce qu'on
appelle intermittence avec les 507
heures qu'ils doivent faire
pendant dix mois avec une date
anniversaire est là depuis on va dire
début mars il ne travaille plus donc non
seulement ils n'ont pas de revenus mais
en plus ils ne peuvent pas avoir droit
au chômage puisqu'il faut avoir fait
cette 507 heures j'espère je pense que
le président va s'exprimer sur ce point
comment faire que ces personnes qu'ils
soient qui sont indispensables à notre
métier m'a la culture rambarde le
spectacle de musique de patates et des
deux tournages de cinéma pour kiel qui
crèvent pas quoi parce que c'est n'ont
rien et c'est pas que les sociétés pathé
potters que l'équateur ne peuvent rien
faire s'il n'y a pas les artistes des
techniciens temps effectivement emmanuel
macron annonçait qu'il prendrait la
parole le 6 mai avec des annonces pour
le milieu de la culture bernard werber
vous en attendez quoi du président de la
république
en effet une aide au monde de l'édition
mais je crois aussi va falloir donner un
grand coup de main aux libraires qui
sont en première ligne et qui sont les
premiers à souffrir à souffrir de cette
crise il ya un comité doit bâtir il ya
tous les gens qui sont dans l'ombre qui
vont aussi répercuté le fait que la
culture n'arrive pas à vivre ce que
j'attends évidemment c'est que c'est une
puisse y avoir une solidarité une aide
aussi avec des artistes etc etc
la culture prennent une place un peu
plus importante
en effet dans les préoccupations du
gouvernement
non justement vous dites de l'aide à
l'édition on imagine que de nombreux de
nombreux des millions de lecteurs
avaient envie peut-être davantage de
l'irs avait peut-être plus le temps est
ce que vous avez quelques informations
justement sur peut-être plus de
téléchargements sur des tablettes ou ou
tout simplement les livres vendus en
grande distribution qui ont augmenté
alors leurs ventes berlin verdun du peu
que j'en sais moi j'ai les informations
utiles viennent à que que des médias
mais du peu que j'en sais je crois qu'en
effet il ya eu beaucoup plus de vente de
deux livres en audio et des ventes de
livres en numérique
tout simplement parce que c'est le seul
moyen de d'avoir du choix
je crois qu'en effet peut-être les
habitudes des français vont changer au
niveau des livres ils vont découvrir en
est chez lui l'utilisation de ces
nouveaux outils sas à risque en effet
d'être mais est ce que c'est bon pour
les pour les libraires ça c'est encore
une autre question mais pas forcément
d'ailleurs effectivement les libraires
qui sont restés fermés dans notre pays
c'était une mauvaise décision d'un
maintien selon vous on aurait du genre
vient la question initiale faire
peut-être davantage pour la culture
c'est vrai qu'il ya pas eu beaucoup
d'initiatives on a vu des rediffusions
de vieux films notamment sur le service
public mais peu de chose en direct on
aurait peut-être pu finalement faire des
concerts à distance entre les musiciens
les diffuser est ce que je sais pas
d'initiative
je ne sais pas parce que je dirais tu
m'en ont été beaucoup être obsessionnel
soul un feu suite moi je suis en panne
création je connais beaucoup de
créateurs on n'arrivait plus à créer
pourtant les tampons filmant parce que
on a poussé pris un choc ça se passera
un traumatisme
ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui c'est unique
s'arrête unis dans le 21e siècle c'est
quelque chose d'incroyable ce que l'on
vit et on qu' on est sûrement très
vilain traumatisant seront pas encore
pompe ce donc
je pense qu'on est tous tournés vers
l'info depuis la recherche surtout
médicales scientifiques
on espérait qu'on essaie de trouver un
signe d'espoir et aujourd'hui pour faire
un petit lien de mon métier je repars
avec des producteurs aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on a aucune visibilité
on sait pas du tout où on va et je crois
que personne ne le sait même les
médecins le savent pas même les
chercheurs ne savent pas on est
complètement dépendant de la recherche
scientifique et en septembre même si on
autorise les théâtres si le poème du
virus n'est pas résolu qui va acheter
les billets de concerts de spectacles
c'est là notre problème c'est que ce
comme disait la dame dont le report
notre reportage on nous n'avons aucune
visibilité
bernard werber le mot de la fin déjà
d'un matière se plaignaient de ne pas
avoir finalement tant d'inspiration ça
pendant cette période de confinement
l'écrivant que vous êtes vous avez été
inspiré oui c'est plus facile pour le
métier d'écrivain de c'est un métier un
peu de moins dans lequel on est déjà
souvent dans un lieu confiné d'habitude
je vais travailler tous les matins en
allant au café donc là je reste chez moi
à travailler en famille c'est un peu
plus compliqué mais j'ai fini par
trouver un nouveau rythme et j'ai
démarré un livre d au début du
confinement qui a rien à voir avec le
sujet de confinement mais dans lequel
j'ai eu l'impression que cette ambiance
différente femme oblige à penser
différemment
je crois que comme disait en matière de
toute façon personne ne sait comment
comment ça va se passer après et moi
aussi je suis très attentif pour pour
essayer de voir comment ça va changer
déjà lu mentalité est ce que les
mentalités ont changé et s'en va s'en
rendre compte dès qu'on sera sorti merci
en tout cas la foulée 2 merci doivent
être remerciés versés pour merci à vous